serrier est employé municipal
il n'a pas quitté boudchar durant
l'occupation de la ville par les russes
il n'a pas non plus attendu leur départ
pour récupérer les corps de dizaines
d'ukrainiens
c'est le périmètre dans lesquelles les
russes nous ont permis de collecter les
corps et de les enterrer
mais quand nokia sortait on dirait sur
leur véhicule au point de contrôle
nos employés ramasser des corps à leurs
risques et périls afin que ces corps ne
soit pas récupérée par les chiens soient
au même moment d'autres hommes
patrouillent un peu plus loin
ramasser les corps de leurs concitoyens
est un devoir moral mais aussi une
nécessité pour récolter des preuves de
ce que tout le monde appelle ici un
crime de guerre
vous pouvez le voir par vous même ce
sont des civils celui ci portait des
pommes de terre et les snipers ont tous
tiré une balle dans la tête par ennui
c'est comme ça qu'ils s'amusaient
et selon la présidence la liste des
exactions et l'ong assassinats tortures
viols de civils pour le président et
l'ins qui la responsabilité de l'armée
russe ne fait aucun doute
pourquoi des civils ordinaires dans une
ville paisible
ont-ils été torturé à mort pourquoi les
femmes douche ont-elles été étranglée
après que leurs boucles d'oreilles ont
été arrachées de leurs oreilles il est
temps de faire tout ce qui est en notre
pouvoir pour faire des crimes de guerre
de l'armée russe sens pas la dernière
manifestation dans tes un mal sur terre
la russie elle rejette de manière
catégorique ces accusations de massacres
de civils
nous rejetons catégoriquement toutes les
accusations
à en juger par ce que nous avons vu on
ne peut pas faire confiance à ces images
vidéo
le pouvoir russe a même demandé une
réunion du conseil de sécurité de l'onu
s'estimant victime d'une tentative de
discrètes